Luffy is going to have the most ridiculously
large and powerful army at the end of one
piece.
We all expect, that this epic series will
have one of the most epic and intense final
battles we have seen in all of Anime.
Eiichiro Oda, the author of one piece himself
has mentioned more than once, that he is working
heatedly on a war that will make the battle
of Marineford look like a playground scruff
between a few third graders.
So assuming that Luffy will actually have
to call all his allies for help is not so
much speculation as a promise, by Oda-sensei
himself.
And so I think it's time to take a look at
all the allies that Luffy has gathered over
the years, that will fight this all-deciding
final war side by side with him against the
full power of the world government, the Gorosei
and Imu.
A war to liberate the world from a tyrannical
and exploitative rule, that has lasted for
over 800 years.
Because as you will realise at the end of
this video, this host is so large and powerful,
that it really raises the question of what
the government has up their sleeve to compete
with it.
At the core of this army of all armies stands
of course the straw hat crew itself, under
the command of the future pirate king Monkey
D. Luffy, a fitting title for a commander
that will lead such a massive host.
The straw hats have pretty much established
themselves as a true Yonko crew at this point.
The top fighters, namely Luffy, Zoro, Sanji,
Jinbe and most likely Yamato are powerful
enough to take on pretty much any opponent
on the grand line at this point.
And even the weakest members, like Usopp,
Nami or Robin have reached a terrifying level
of power in battle.
As a crew with unwavering believe and a wide
variety of devil fruit abilities and other
useful skills, the straw hat will lead the
final fleet into battle.
The first massive addition to the straw hat
army is of course the straw hat grand fleet,
that was established during the aftermath
of the Dressrosa arc.
An impressive host of 5640 men, consisting
of seven pirate crews that were enslaved or
imprisoned by the Donquixote family in one
way or the other.
We're talking giants, long arms, the tontatta,
cavendish's crew and of course my man Bartholomeo.
While the grand fleet will add impressive
numbers to the main army, I think it's important
to remember that many of its members are top
tier fighters, that fought in the colloseum.
Many have haki or devil fruit powers and especially
the new giant warrior pirates under the lead
of Hajrudin, will have a massive impact on
the battle field.
The other major force Luffy will be able to
count on is of course the Ninja-Pirate-Mink-Samurai
Alliance, that was formed in front of the
Road Poneglyph on Zou.
I personally think that this force will be
even more important and power-packed than
the grand fleet.
The samurai and ninja of Wano are known as
probably the most powerful people in the entire
new world, with fighters strong enough to
oppose the government for centuries.
Not only do most of them have advanced haki
in the form of Ryou, but the country is full
of special ability users, including the likes
of Onimaru, Tama or Momo, who has the same
mythical devil fruit as Kaido himself.
Then there are the two pirate crews involved
in this as well, that have already fought
side by side with Luffy in a battle to the
death.
Law's heart pirates and the Kid pirates, despite
their pride and brawls with Luffy, have been
established as allies and believers in Luffy,
that will stand by his side against a larger
evil, be it Kaido or the world government
itself.
Wether other supernova will join the fray,
we'll have to wait and see, but many of them
do seem like likely candidates.
X drake has already fought with Luffy, Hawkings
will probably switch sides, Bonny, who's connected
to Kuma and has infiltrated Marijois, I could
see many of them standing side by side with
Luffy at the end as well.
The minks of course aren't far off in terms
of their fighting power.
They have been surviving and defending their
home against powerful invaders for centuries
as well and especially under the full-moon,
become one of the most fear-inducing weapons
you could wish for.
Oh and speaking of their home country, Zuneshia,
the gignatuous elephant that Zou is located
on is of course gonna be part of this as well.
No matter if it's an actual ancient weapon
or just a monstrous walking tank of destruction,
Zuneshia is gonna have to play a central role
in the final battle, that most likely will
be tied to its past relationship with JoyBoy
in some way or form.
And speaking of ancient weapons, and another
race that owes its freedom to the straw hats,
are Shirahoshi and the fishmen.
Now that I think about it, I guess technically
Fishman island is actually still luffy's territory
if I'm not mistaken.
With the fishman once again, we have once
again have a race of powerful fighters, that
has been suppressed and discriminated against
for hundreds of years.
Not only are they able to fight underwater,
manipulate currents and attack ships from
below, but their princess, the ancient weapon
Poseidon, is literally able to control the
sea kings, mysterious giant sea monsters,
similar to Zuneshia, who's powers are pretty
much forces of nature.
At this point I think two pretty clear patterns
emerge.
Luffy's most terrifying ability, as Mihawk
calls it, to bring people to his side, fight
for him and believe in him, can be divided
into two categories: On the one hand you have
people who have been liberated and saved by
Luffy.
This is true for pretty much all of the straw
hats in some way or form, Robin from Enies
Lobby, Sanji from Whole cake island, Joinbei
from impel down, but of course also for entire
islands, including the fishman, whom he saved
from hody jones and their internal dispute
about their racial identity, wano from Kaido's
tyrannical rule or Law from his obsession
with Doflamingo and his quest to avenge Corazon.
Luffy saving people and bringing them out
of their darkness, no matter who you are and
what you have done, has always been one of
his most powerful character traits.
My favorite example here is probably Katakuri,
whom Luffy saved from his isolation among
his crew and the pressure he felt to never
be himself and show any weakness.
Katakuri by the way is also someone I really
expect to stand by Luffy's side at the end.
On the other hand, there are also many people,
that Luffy has brought to his side by earning
their respect and inspiring them to entrust
their hopes and dreams into him.
A great example here would for example be
Whitebeard.
Luffy did not manage to save either Whitebeard,
nor his brother Ace.
But his actions and will earned him the Yonko's
respect and as a result, Luffy has the powerful
remnants of the Whitebeard pirates on his
side, including Marco and Izo, both of which
fought with him on Wano.
In the same way, Luffy has inspired Mihawk
to help Zoro and very possibly help the crew
again in the future.
Even though there is of course more to it,
it is all the reason why Shanks and Rayleigh
and possibly other former members of the Roger
pirates will be fighting by his side as well.
Eustass Kid, falls into this category as well.
As I discussed in his character analysis video,
it was Luffy's stubbornness, his willingness
to die and fight for him without any second
thoughts, that ultimately made Kid trust him
fully.
Another really big ally for Luffy in the final
battle will of course be his father dragon
and the revolutionary army as a whole.
The revolutionary are already dangerous enough
as an organisation that Dragon has become
the most wanted man in the world.
Not only do they have agents everywhere across
the globe and most likely inside the world
government ranks as well, but they also have
real heavy hitters in their ranks, including
the commanders, Luffy's brother sabo, Ivankov
and the entirety of the Kamabakka kingdom.
And we're not even talking about all the possible
intel that Dragon might have about the true
history and the secrets of the world government.
The revolutionaries might end up being one
of the most crucial pieces for Luffy's success
and the downfall of the Gorosei and Imu.
But there are also forces within the marines
themselves, that seem likely to side with
Luffy at some point.
Characters like Smoker or Fujitora, who have
opposed Luffy, but ended up respecting and
cheering for him as they witnessed his kindness
and more importantly the incompetency and
corruption of the government to keep its citizens
save from harm.
You have characters like Koby, who not only
has been one of Luffy's friends since the
very beginning, but just like X Drake is part
of the secret marine organisation sword, that
is opposed to the the world Nobel's cruelty
and is fighting for a more just and fair version
of the marines.
And of course we shouldn't forget Kuzan, who
has been friendly towards Luffy and the straw
hats right from the start and who has been
off doing his own mysterious thing for a while
now.
He seems like the type of character who would
side with the straw hats in their fight for
a just and free world, which would add one
of the most powerful characters in the entire
story to Luffy's ranks.
Someone who has control over the ocean itself
would be a more than valuable asset in the
final war.
Luffy's Grandfather garp is another candidate
here.
He will not watch another one of his grandkids
die.
He will fight on Luffy's side in the next
big war.
And there are even more potential allies that
might join the fight.
The warriors of Skypea, another ancient race
associated with the ancient kingdom, might
come to Luffy's aid.
The giants of elbaf, another big arc that
is coming up, will surely also end up as allies
to the crew.
Similarly, soldiers from kingdoms like Drum
island with Dalton and Kureha, Dressrosa with
King Riku and rebekka and Alabasta with Vivi
should join the battle as well.
And speaking of Dressrosa, Luffy liberated
the country from the rule of the Donxiquote
family, which includes the weirdly thin, but
very slimy Trebol.
It has been my mission for a while now to
overtake his bounty of 99M berries.
With 100 berries per subscriber, we still
have 40M berries to go, so please help me
overtake this man by subscribing to the channel.
More warlords.
Boa Hancock will be fighting for Luffy just
as surely as Zoro will.
Many of the impel down prisoners that Luffy
helped break out, including Crocodile, Buggy
and hopefully the one and only Mr. 2.
Kuma, who was part of the revolutionaries
and has helped the crew before.
And who knows, maybe Vegapunk will actually
turn out to be an ally as well, as many people
have speculated before, adding incredible
technical knowledge and prowess to the mix.
Sanji's family the Vinsmokes and their Germa
army should be on their side at this point
as well.
And the biggest wildcard of them all is most
likely Shanks and the red hair pirates.
However, should they actually survive AND
be the good guys after all, having them join
Luffy's grand fleet would instantly increase
their power multiple times.
I mean seriously, getting another Yonko crew
would just really turn this into the ultimate
force to wage the largest war the world has
ever seen.
So I just want you to close your eyes and
imagine this army for a second.
While nations, the most powerful fighters
on the ocean, ancient weapons and invincible
Devil fruits all united under the straw hat
banner.
All of this of course leaves us with one big
question: What sort of terrifying secret power
does the world government and Imu have up
their sleeve to counter this sort of army
to make it a fair fight?
The next arc on the way to this major battle
is going to be Elbaf.
And if you want to know what might happen
on the island of the giants, you really shouldn't
ignore this video right here.